Alright guys, so here is the last example for this strategy and
I'm looking at USTCHF. I
Also want to like I'm showing you guys that it works with every single pair. Okay, so
Autoflow is clearly bearish. You have to train your eyes to see this
so now
We have this autoblock here
Prize comes back into our autoblock. Let's go back to 15 minute and you can see that
We have higher high high low and higher high
Now this here right here candle, right? It took out
This liquidity here and then we have a
Market structure shift here very tiny market structure shift, but it is a
Market structure shift. Let's go back to like let's say five minutes
You can see that this is a clear clean market structure shift, right?
now, let's go back to 15 minute and
Now it doesn't have to be consecutive candles. I know some of you might think that it has to be consecutive
No
If it takes out liquidity and then you have if it takes out liquidity
It goes to your POI and then you have a market structure shift
Then that is your autoblock. Okay, it doesn't have to be consecutive candles
You take your entry here put your stop right above this high over here
go for one two and
and
Look at this
plays out beautifully and
It hits your take profit
Honestly, this is one of my favorite trading strategies at the moment
It's basically autoflow
But it only uses two time frames and you only have to see the market structure shift during kills on ours
And your entry must also be doing kills on ours and you go for one to two
So that was it for this strategy. I'll see you guys in the next one